hi everyone sal khan here welcome to
homeroom with sal we have a very
exciting show today after a bit of a
hiatus we haven't done a live stream uh
in a little while but we have vas
narasimhan who is the ceo of novartis we
had him on last year at the early phases
of the pandemic and so you can imagine
there's there's a lot to talk about
there but also just generally about
medical science and running a large
multinational organization so if you
have questions start thinking of them
put them in the message boards on
facebook or youtube or wherever you
happen to be watching
this live stream but before we jump into
it with vass i will make my standard
announcements uh first of all i want to
remind everyone we are not for profit we
can only exist with philanthropic
donations so
if you are in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
donate and donations of all size make a
big big difference for our our mission
of trying to educate the world i also
want to make a special shout out
to a whole series of organizations that
stepped up when they realized that khan
academy as expenses only went up when
the world started to depend on it even
more during the global school closures
so special thanks to bank of america att
google.org novartis fastly and general
motors and then last but not least i
want to remind folks that there is a
podcast version of this live stream
homeroom with sal the podcast wherever
you get your podcasts so with that i am
super excited to welcome back
back to our live stream and you know in
full disclosure y'all are one of our uh
sponsors so thank you also and and you
know people should also know i'm
somewhat biased towards you and novartis
so
to take everything we say with a grain
of salt but welcome back vas
great to be here sal and i've even put
on a my kids gave me a khan academy
sticker to really be part of the cause
so we're thrilled to support khan
academy i think it's amazing what all of
you do and look forward to the
discussions
you know i'm both heartened and
disappointed by what you just said um
i'm heartened that you're wearing a khan
academy sticker i'm i'm disappointed
that your kids had to force you to wear
that i'd like to think that in your
day-to-day management of of running uh
you know one of the largest farmer
companies in the world you wear a khan
academy sticker but but maybe that will
change i'll take that on advise myself
[Laughter]
well you know maybe a good place to
start and i actually have a question
obviously we're in i guess i don't know
what we call it year two now of of covet
19. some people are saying it should be
called kova 20 now with the the delta
variant and i've heard this word
syndemic
um
and i'm hearing an oxy in kind of pharma
medical circles my wife's a doctor as
well what is a syndemic
endemic is the term we use kind of for a
parallel epidemic that's happening
alongside the pandemic i mean what we
saw throughout last year is
unfortunately as covet took hold across
health care systems that patients didn't
get the routine care they need for
things like cancer cardiovascular
disease lung disease a range of
different diseases part of that where
patients were afraid to go to the
hospital a big part of that where
hospitals were just so busy caring for
covet patients and what that leads to is
when patients aren't getting their
normal care for non-communicable
diseases like heart disease or cancer
those diseases get worse actually it's
even harder to treat those patients
later on now we saw that improve in the
first part of this year as it looked
like things were getting better
unfortunately now as delta variant kind
of takes hold again we're seeing it
again be an issue i'm hopeful that
healthcare systems can figure out a way
to continue to see patients so they get
the care they need
yeah it's a fascinating question because
we've talked a lot about school closures
and learning laws it's one of these
things where we as human beings will
obviously watch the news and we'll see
people who are you know getting
hospitalized and intubated or worse
because of the pandemics so that feels
very urgent and then a lot of what we
try to do at khan academy is remind
folks well you know there's also side
effects of kids not being in school in
fact long term they could be even larger
side effects more harm to more kids than
even the pandemic itself and what you're
bringing up is even though our health
care system is operating and doing
incredible things
when the pandemic picks up and
especially once icus fill up or fit
people are afraid to go to the hospital
it's creating a bit of a a health loss
of a health debt uh which my wife has
also described like she just started now
that she's seeing more patients in
person she's seeing how much how many of
her patients have really degraded um in
in the time that they've they've they
were afraid or they couldn't come to the
hospital how how does novartis you know
before we started recording i i actually
didn't fully appreciate you know a lot
of people when they talk about the
vaccines they're talking about pfizer
moderna and j j but i didn't realize
that y'all were actually one of the
larger producers of vaccines uh but
above and beyond i'm curious how that's
been going but above and beyond that
when you're running a large
one of the largest pharma companies in
the world i believe the largest producer
of pharmaceuticals
you know what what what is the the
pandemic or the syndemic has that
changed what y'all are doing and does it
change how you think about what your
your your your goals as an organization
it's kind of it's not a lot of different
impacts just to give your listeners a
sense of scope i mean so we are about
110 000 people operate in 150 countries
we produce about 70 billion doses of
medicine a year and an unusual year we
reach about 800 million patients with
those with those medicines so a very
very large large scale
now of course when you have something
like this disrupt healthcare systems it
impacts you know our business also
impacts our ability to run clinical
trials many of our clinical trials were
disrupted we've had to do a lot of work
to keep clinical trials and clinical
research um going at an appropriate pace
one of the other challenges that we see
from a clinical standpoint is i'm sure
your wife is seeing this as well if you
see cancer patients who are treated
later
usually the medicines have a harder and
harder time having their effect if
patients are more progressed similarly
in heart disease or lung disease um so
we're trying to educate policy makers i
think health ministers that i speak with
are are very aware of this challenge but
it is a very human challenge in the end
people can get very afraid to go to the
hospital and they put off routine care
or very routine screening in the case of
many of these diseases now you also
asked about vaccine production i mean um
i know our part i think is small
relative to many of the the companies
that are the innovators of these
vaccines but given our very large
manufacturing footprint we are able to
produce vaccines here in switzerland and
our facilities in austria to support you
know the global global pandemic and it's
it's something i think we feel like is
part of our responsibility
as a large healthcare company
i never thought about it we were talking
about this endemic just now and how
other types of things could be slowed
down or there could be a health debt but
i never thought about the impact on
critical clinical trials themselves
do you think industry-wide this is
actually slowing down some some drugs
that could have gone to market sooner
i mean i think it remains to be seen i
mean companies have been working really
hard like for instance and one of the
big transitions we've seen is just to
use technology to keep people on
clinical trials so clinical trials used
to be a very human
uh heavy endeavor and now we're using
you know remote monitoring to monitor
the patients on our clinical trials keep
them on steady but i do think you'll see
some impacts for sure i mean if you just
think about the disruption a clinical
trial anyway such a hard thing to run if
suddenly like an entire country says no
patients can come into the hospital and
then suddenly that country is shut down
for your clinical trial then you have to
go to another country these creates
disruptions in your data sets and then
when you run the statistics statistics
that many people learn about through
khan academy
those statistics get harder to run
because you have to account for all of
these disruptions that have happened
in the studies
i would say though overall at least
we've been able to manage you know
reasonably well
yeah no no it's fascinating and i will
as an aside give you full credit you are
the best guest when it comes to plugging
khan academy beyond the sticker on your
shirt
if you mention statistics you remind
everyone it can be learned on khan
academy so
special you know
my friend completed the statistics
course on khan academy so that's why i
knew about the statistics i was getting
my own refresher on some of these topics
i think i'm going to send you another
sticker vest
well i mean well you know getting
getting to more serious topics which
which i unfortunately took us on a
tangent
you know the vax the vaccines itself
that you know
thank god thank the universe that that
we now have them obviously it's somewhat
been politicized where not everyone is
is taking them but but what's your view
of how this is going to play out
obviously that you know i remember last
year i was watching some news channel
and there was some epidemiologist who
seemed like doom and gloom who's like
we're nev you know this thing's always
going to be here it's going to be like
the flu it's going to be constantly
evolving we're just going to have to
live with kovid in the future and i
remember at the time everyone i think
thought that guy was a wet blanket like
it's not going to be that way
now it's starting to feel like that guy
might have been right obviously you have
the delta variant people are talking
about booster shots people are talking
about
do we need a delta aware vaccine what's
your view of all of this you know are
people working on a delta aware vaccine
is this going to constantly evolve will
there be a you know a gamma and an omega
covet-21 well how do you think this is
going to happen
yeah so a few big principle points i
think it's worth for the listeners to to
understand i mean one we're surrounded
by viruses i mean you think like a cup
of seawater you have billions or
trillions of viruses and viruses
actually probably enabled the first
prokaryotic and eukaryotic cells maybe
even multi-cellular life so we live with
viruses
and then when you look at coronaviruses
there are four normally circulating
coronaviruses that cause the common cold
alongside many other viruses that we
deal with um as the human species and
that we've adapted to
so usually with these types of
respiratory viruses the expectation is
eventually we will reach an equilibrium
state where the virus evolves to a place
where it is causing
minimally symptomatic disease but
enabling spread think about the common
cold runny nose all those things and our
immune systems get primed enough that we
can handle that that assault because we
have memory in our t cells we also have
memory in our b cells and we're able to
deal with like as we do with other
coronaviruses what we're observing right
now is that process happening and the
virus is mutating our immune systems are
developing vaccines are hopefully
enabling our immune systems to get
stronger and clearly are and then are
enabling us to adapt
and the question is how can we as a
global society best manage that to
minimize the impact as we get to that
equilibrium so that's kind of the way i
think about the the big picture it's
hard to know when exactly that
equilibrium will happen but it will but
i think it's reasonable to expect that
this coronavirus will become a normal
circulating coronavirus like we have
other coronaviruses
and cause you know symptomatic
respiratory illness but probably nothing
severe because we have adapted to it as
a species
now in the meantime the question is how
much do we need to keep working on
future vaccines and i think it's an open
question i think we have to be driven by
data
the data would seem to suggest that the
current vaccines produce a very robust
memory response
it also seems naturally effective people
are producing a memory response
that's why we see less severe disease
and less hospitalizations and deaths and
people who are
previously vaccinated but people who are
previously vaccinated are able to get
infected and spread and so um we're
gonna have to see i think in the coming
months how the the data plays out how
the booster shots really look from a
data standpoint and i think the health
authorities then will will figure out
what the right right path for it is but
i think it's worth remembering that this
is going to be an equilibrium that
happens over time also i think it's an
incredible accomplishment of modern
science that by the end of this year my
guesses will have over 10 billion
doses of vaccine produced
which is really less than 18 20 months
from when we first characterized this
virus that's an astonishing scientific
achievement
no it is incredible and
you know they're
just following on this notion that
vaccines are constantly evolving i mean
actually i just i redid a khan academy
video yesterday about about evolution
and natural selection and i i know
sometimes people say oh this goes over
you know something that you don't
necessarily see it occurs over millions
of years i'm like no you're seeing it
before your eyes with these variants of
these viruses and you're seeing it every
year with the flu virus evolution is
happening and and to your point
selection pressure for a virus it
wouldn't it wouldn't naturally select
for viruses that are necessarily more
deadly it's actually not in the viruses
interest to kill the host
now i think everyone's nightmare
scenarios are something that spreads
like delta you know it's very easy to
spread it can kind of evade at least the
first phases of the immune system uh and
then kind of stays dormant while it
spreads and then becomes worse and then
becomes deadly
is is
is it just kind of dark science fiction
thinking that we we could go in in that
direction because i guess i guess the
argument is evolution wouldn't wouldn't
select for something like that it could
randomly happen because we have
so many hosts right now billions of
hosts each with
billions of virus viruses in them that
that is is maybe accelerating the
evolution to some degree
yeah i think it's i mean certainly all
possible but in general what we do
observe in viruses and again if you look
at para influenza viruses and
rhinoviruses and other coronaviruses the
tropism and the way they tend to evolve
is to be
symptom minimally symptomatic and very
transmissible because they actually want
you to move around and behave normally
because that's how the gene as you
likely
taught in the natural selection class
will then pass on to the next generation
and the viruses will propagate if you
look at other examples things like you
know the some of the hemorrhagic fevers
that come out of africa
um
whether it's ebola marburg loss they
have very high case fatality rates but
they usually burn out because eventually
they kill the host so fast the
transmission doesn't happen and those
tend to be
very contained so that is what the
history would tell us and how you would
expect for this to play out i think even
if you had a very um you know more
virulent strain again the human immune
system is designed to especially for
these kinds of respiratory viruses to
develop a very robust immune response
but what you invariably have when you
have that happen is you will have a bump
in severe cases you know when when such
of ours comes about
but i overall sell remain optimistic i
mean when i look at these kinds of
respiratory viruses and how in a big
picture of you how they tend to settle
in in human populations they tend to
trend towards an equilibrium state of
minimally symptomatic or mildly
symptomatic cold like uh respiratory
condition
then we wouldn't even notice um and we
would just say oh it's just another
circulating cold virus
right and and we have historical
examples of that the flu obviously at
one point the flu was
scary very scary it's still not
completely not scary but it's it's it's
much more maintainable you know big
question and it connects with what we
often talk about education is you know
vaccines for younger people what's your
view of
uh why it is taking longer and
what we might expect to see in the next
few months when we might be able to
vaccinate 12 and under and i am also
curious i've had a very u.s specific
view on that what are other countries
doing on on the vaccination of younger
people
so first i think it's again worth
looking at how astonishing the
achievement of pediatric vaccination has
been i mean if you look actually back
over the last century
the biggest public health intervention
along with clean water that's happened
in human history is actually pediatric
vaccination it's astonishing what
pediatric vaccination has been able to
accomplish and we often forget that
because we just don't see
mumps and measles and rubella and all of
these conditions any longer pneumococcal
i mean
meningitis because these vaccines have
been so
affected um and so one i think it's
worth reminding ourselves that when we
do get a pediatric vaccine approved
people if
should really look to vaccinate children
it's one of the most successful public
health interventions that we've that
we've ever had
now in terms of usually how vaccines are
developed
and including drugs as well is we step
down through the age groups because we
want to ensure that there's a good
safety profile because children's
children's immune systems you of course
want to ensure that you're not going to
have any adverse consequences and so i
think that's what's being systematically
done
usually historically what you do is you
get down to 11 year olds then 2 to 10
year olds and then under 2 years old and
again it's worth remembering that most
children in the world get a lot of
vaccines when they're two months of age
that's actually when we start
vaccinating so we'll see how the data
develops on that front but my guess is
over time we'll be getting down in those
younger and younger age groups i think
many countries around the world are
similar to the us now at the 12 plus age
range
um and then i think over the coming
months we'll be able to get into the
pediatric age range and then younger as
well
and does it change depending on what
i'm assuming there's certain safety
profiles you have to test a vaccine in a
certain scale
normally but when you're in something of
a public health emergency like this does
do they change the rules or do they just
try to run the the trials faster how do
they expedite things
well first i would say this vaccine
these vaccines have the biggest safety
databases of maybe any vaccines right
now you have billions of doses and so
the denominators here are remarkable to
look at uh any you know adverse event
and well i think the understandably
there is news media pick up whenever
there is any sort of event it's
important to recognize that in most
cases these are astonishingly rare and
and you have more risk getting in your
car in the morning than you do of
any of these these very rare adverse
events for vaccines and it's it's so
very hard as you know for the human mind
to assess risk but i think one of the
useful things to do is compare it to the
other risks you take every single day
living your life and you see that these
risks are actually quite small um the
way the clinical trials are they're
using pretty standard clinical trials
and i would say my own experience in
vaccines these numbers are very large
that they're using i mean most of the
databases here in the clinical studies
are fifty thousand to a hundred thousand
plus patients those are very robust
databases to identify significant safety
signals including in children so i would
feel very confident that the regulators
and the companies are doing the right
thing here
yeah and you know that last point about
stack ranking the things that are
dangerous in life you know until we have
a vaccine for younger kids at least here
in the u.s we've heard stories now that
school is starting up
you know pretty pretty scary stories of
10 20 of kindergarteners not showing up
because parents are are afraid of the
delta variant and it is scary i have one
of my oldest got vaccinated he's 12 but
my other two are not vaccinated so i
definitely feel that but at the same
time you know just my own curiosity i
started looking up uh you know
hospitalizations and deaths and it does
not even the delta variant does not seem
dramatically different i might be wrong
or maybe the data hasn't fully come in
yet uh with with the flu uh and both of
them are actually less likely to kill a
young person to your point than a car or
a swimming pool um so so
you know for those of you in the like
what would be your advice uh to to a
parent who's scared right now especially
if they can't get their kids vaccinated
yeah i think i think again when you look
at the data it would suggest that
especially in younger children that the
risk here is very small and even
infected children
despite the one-off news media reports
that you're hearing and you know you're
seeing very low rates of hospitalization
or severe disease and my guess is it's
probably even better than we see in the
data because the denominator of number
of children or adults who are
asymptomatically infected or not
captured is quite significant there have
been very good models that have been
produced by different
economists and epidemiologist that would
suggest
five ten maybe more fold under counting
of the denominator which means that the
actual
rate of hospitalization rate of seduce
if your disease rate of death is even
lower than what we might might think
otherwise
so um you know i would i would if the
school is open and the school has
appropriate precautions i think the
damage we could be doing to children by
not ensuring that they're continuing to
have their socio their social
development their educational
development that's something we've got
to factor into but one of the things i
think i'm sure you're also concerned
about globally
the loss of years of education and the
impact that will have on the long-term
mental and social well-being for these
generations of children is substantial
and should be counted right and counted
and considered whenever we think about
school lockdowns and school closures
yeah couldn't agree more but it is it's
going to be interesting how this plays
out well well thank you for indulging me
and all of us and you know i actually
give credit to raynor rustenberg
they asked a couple of questions that i
i paraphrased a little bit so i want to
make sure that that youtube viewer gets
proper credit for the questions um but i
do want to shift a little bit you know i
i could talk for hours about the vaccine
and how all of this might evolve uh but
i also want to be forward learning
looking post pandemic or maybe it's
related to the pandemic i mean you're
running
one of the largest pharmaceutical
companies in the world
what what
what are you excited about where is
medicine going well you know
i think medicine
a lot of people compare education to
medicine and they're like look at what
medicine has done in the last 50 years
and education a lot of good in education
but it looks like it's fairly similar to
the way it was 50 years ago or 100 years
ago hopefully some of that will change
for the better but
what do you think medicine is going to
look like if we fast forward 5 years 10
years 20 years
yeah it's interesting i mean right now
we're undergoing really a substantial
renaissance and how we think about
therapeutics in
in medicine i mean we go again back in
history
it was really in the early 1900s we
began to think about medicine as being
able to you know impact the human body
and before then we had
much less sophisticated views on how to
impact health we started with chemicals
so chemistry
small molecule
chemicals that would interact with
proteins to try to get a therapeutic
effect around the 1970s 1980s we moved
into the world of producing large
molecules so proteins to impact proteins
or proteins to bind other proteins or
proteins to find other things in the
body that's called biologics we had
small molecules and biologics and then
there wasn't another revolution until
pretty recently where now there's been
an explosion of a few different
technologies some of them we work on
gene therapies which allow us to
edit the genome of
patients to really correct for inherited
abnormalities you have cell therapies
which are taking cells out of the body
reprogramming them using technologies
like you've heard of like crispr
that then reprogram the cells put them
back in the body uh we have rna and
everybody knows about mrna the other
revolution that's happened that was
years in the making going back to work
done in the 1970s and 1980s is to
understand how rna modulates other rna
and there's technologies called
antisense oligonucleotides or silencing
rnas which can be used as therapeutics
and those are now getting approved as
well so we're using rna as therapeutics
these are very small strands of rna now
all of these areas are opening up whole
new all of these technologies such as
they're opening up whole new fields of
medicine that we think where we can
treat diseases that we haven't been able
to treat in the past when you think
about the numbers rough numbers here we
can treat about 700 of the roughly 8 000
to 10 000
diseases that are in the various
compendiums so there's still a lot of
opportunity for us to improve human
health and these technologies are
helping us do that the other big
revolution now is data science and ai
which i'm sure you talked about i know
it's impacting education impacting our
industry as well so how can you use ai
to find new drugs to develop drugs
faster to produce those drugs more
efficiently
probably many people would have seen
that um
you know google recently published the
the structures or deep mind
published the structures of all proteins
that they've been able to identify thus
far in the database which is again a
massive accomplishment and done through
artificial intelligence
you know it is mind-boggling and i mean
i was good i was thinking about asking
but when will we see this but then i
realized we actually are seeing it it's
happening behind the scenes i mean even
my wife who's a rheumatologist she's
saying you know the the medications the
drugs that she has access to
even 20 years ago
they were just maintaining the pain
while now they can actually start to
provide therapies and treat
you know if we go 10 15 years in the
future are there certain areas that
you're specif you know particularly
hopeful about or maybe you just don't
want to jinx it yet but you know i'm
sure there's areas that y'all are
investing in that you think that there's
there's space for for some innovation
yeah i think a few areas that we have
the opportunity i mean the goal of
course is to get to a larger absolute
efficacy gain and can you really get to
maybe even cures and remissions when you
look at the whole world of blood cancers
it's astonishing i mean the progress
we're making and i'm hopeful that we can
get to a world with all of the efforts
in the in the our sector and with
academia and government that maybe
nobody needs to die from a blood cancer
given the pace of innovation we're
seeing there it's pretty remarkable
when you look at certain rare diseases
we already have a medicine that when
given to a child early enough i can
almost eliminate the what would have
other otherwise have been a certainly
terminal disease for these children and
that's with a single uh injection of
that gene therapy so i think in certain
rare diseases you're going to see
astonishing progress we're big believers
in cardiovascular still it's worth
remembering the largest cause of death
and disability in the world is heart
disease even more than any infection i
haven't checked the numbers it may still
have over outdone covid last year as
well in terms of overall death and
disability so i think advances in
cardiovascular
disease are an opportunity to maybe not
have people die from heart attacks or
subsequent heart attacks so those are
areas of tremendous opportunity
cardiovascular disease cancer etc i mean
the places where we have a lot of work
to do
is i'm i'm still understanding better
the biology of the brain
cognitive disorder psychiatric disorders
neurodegenerative disorders
um the brain is a remarkable
feat of billions of years of evolution
but still
a lot of work to do to understand what's
going on in the diseases of the brain
yeah well no it makes me it makes me
make me very helpful
very very hopeful uh for where we're
going and and i know you know whenever i
could talk to you literally for hours
hopefully we'll get a chance to do that
uh but i just glanced at the clock it's
like oh we're almost out of time uh so
so vas you know i just wanted to thank
you incredibly i i have to say it you
know and i'm not saying this just
because novartis is one of the major
supporters of khan academy i think i
would say this regardless but talking to
you is incredibly refreshing because
there's a whole ceo part of your job
which you know the ceo part of my job
which i try to do vaguely competently is
hard uh and and we are about 200 folks
you are talking about 100 thousand plus
employees and so you must be incredible
at that but just speaking to you on
science the fact how deep you can go and
that we can kind of nerd out together uh
while you're also managing a hundred
thousand plus you know major
pharmaceutical uh uh entity you know
that's giving drugs to 800 million
people um it's kind of mind-blowing but
at the same time heartening uh to see
how deep you can go so so thank you for
and then your willingness to talk to me
thank you
for any students out there i'm still a
scientist
at heart and i think i hope i can prove
that you can be a scientist and work in
the business world but stay passionate
about science and medicine because what
wakes me up every day is those amazing
findings that we have that can transform
human life so always grateful to be here
and look forward to the next
conversation so
yeah you know in the and amongst like
actors and stuff there's the notion of a
double threat of a triple threat if you
can act and sing or you know act and
sing and dance uh you can learn
we'll talk about that next time no no my
kids would tell you i cannot act or sing
so they prefer me to stick with being a
ceo
excellent excellent well thank you so
much vas and and and and say hi to your
kids one more khan academy users and
distributing khan academy stickers which
i appreciate
all right take care
yeah
well well thanks everyone for joining i
hope you enjoyed that conversation with
bass and i said it i meant it it's
actually incredibly refreshing uh when
you meet someone who leads a
multinational organization like that uh
but who can also really go deep and
clearly has a passion for for what they
do and and the impact they're having on
the planet uh so hopefully you found
that as inspiring as i did and i look
forward uh to seeing you all next time
we are going to have a homeroom it's
going to be with our chief learning
officer kristen deterbo going to talk to
our head of content adam green about all
of the new content and course refreshers
on khan academy and i don't want to pick
favorites because there's a lot of new
content but we've been doing a big
science push
you know that video i just talked about
around gene expression and around
evolution that's part of our science
push so you know keep a lookout for that
but you'll hear much more about it on
the ed talks with kristin ducerbo and
adam tomorrow so with that i will i will
see you all later
onward
you